deutschland ist also betroffen aber es
gibt eine kleine insel
dort ist dass wir uns noch nicht
angekommen und das ist helgoland
besucher fahren nicht mehr auf die
beliebte tourismus insel auf der fähre
sind gerade mal 24 von über 1000
möglichen passagieren an bord gelten
höchste sicherheitsmaßnahmen beim
betreten des schiffs muss ein
mindestabstand von zwei metern
eingehalten werden das gastro personal
darf passagiere nicht bedienen jeder
zweite tisch muss frei bleiben und die
gäste müssen sich essen getränke in der
küche selbst abholen 63 kilometer
entfernt gelten auf helgoland ähnlichen
einreisebeschränkungen wie in den usa
normalerweise fährt die fähre sieben mal
pro woche von cuxhaven nach helgoland
zurzeit sind es nur zwei mal die
einbußen durch den aus kleiner tourismus
haben finanzielle folgen der pächter
verhandelt mit seiner bank um die
monatlichen betriebskosten von 15.000
euro zahlen zu können
der fähren betreiber soll sogar
zuschüsse aus der gemeindekasse erhalten
um weiter die insel anfahren zu können
hier auf helgoland gibt es noch keine
cholera fälle und das soll auch so
bleiben
bürgermeister jörg singer hat alle
touristen vom festland geschickt also
wieder ganz besonderen phase die sonne
scheint und eigentlich sind hier kommen
täglich 1500 gäste jetzt ist alles
anders
eine sinnvolle maßnahme für den kampf
gegen das virus doch eine katastrophe
für händler und geschäfte die vom
tourismus leben alle insel restaurants
und souvenirläden sind dicht mein name
ist also lukas ich lebe seit 22 jahren
auf helgoland und betreiber die latics
fischerstube hier auf helgoland
eigentlich würde die saison jetzt
losgehen wir würden uns auf viele gäste
freuen aber leider bleibt es im moment
aus und wir versuchen unsere sechs
mitarbeiter über die zeit jetzt
durchzuziehen hoffen dass es bald wieder
losgeht
existenzängste schulden vielen menschen
droht möglicherweise das finanzielle aus
das corona virus bestimmt das leben auf
helgoland auch wenn es dort noch keine
infizierten gibt patienten aus dem
krankenhaus haben die insel verlassen in
der klinik wurden die betten für
mögliche corona fälle geräumt
bürgermeister singer blickt positiv in
die zukunft und hofft dass bis zum
ersten januar die korona krise
überstanden ist damit sich die
helgoländer zum traditionellen wünsch
treffen wieder die hand geben können